today's top of the try guys they just
released a video statement recently if
you aren't aware the try guys are a
group that emanated from the BuzzFeed
era and then went out to create their
own successful channel it's for dudes to
try a bunch of stuff now they do
sketches different things like that very
popular brand okay trash it now one of
the individuals uh who's the I love my
wife guy he's married uh you know with a
wife and kids four weeks ago was at a
weekend out public partying
and somebody snapped a picture of him uh
making out with an Asian woman who
wasn't his wife
um
if that was confusing his wife's not
Asian I don't know why included a
warmest let's hear the video statement
because uh now they're talking about it
Ned Fulmer is no longer working with the
try guys
by now we're assuming you've seen the
Reddit threads and tick tocks and tweets
and news articles we want to give you a
timeline of what's transpired and some
transparency into our decision making
throughout this video there will be
things that we want to say or go into
further but as I'm sure you're aware
there are some legal issues we have to
consider as we go through everything
on Labor Day weekend multiple fans
alerted us that they had seen Ned and an
employee engaging in public romantic
Behavior an employee is one of their
employees yeah I know where you're going
you don't know where I'm going okay I
don't know where you're going we don't
have any Asian employees
that's not where I was going
okay I'm not understood but I know where
you thought I was going because you
don't know everyone involved in HRS or
maybe you were misunderstanding where I
was going I know where you're going what
happened to the girl
none of the women who worked for us I
would not be involved that's not what
I'm talking about [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of this [ __ ] that's not even
I'm not improving myself I didn't do
nothing
I know where you're going with this
you're a liar yeah yeah yeah
let that [ __ ] go huh I was home last
weekend shut up [ __ ]
we're burners
sorry I'm just trolling so hard some of
you are close to my [ __ ] Google feeds
trying to find out who works for chill
out nothing happened but that's gonna be
the next big thing
I have a telling on himself when we
stopped to check on that employee uh Ned
confirmed the reports and since
confirmed that this has been going on
for some time which was obviously very
shocking to us and we just want you to
know that we had no idea this was going
on all of that information was just as
shocking to us as all of this has been
for you this week and let's begin a
three week process of engaging with
employment lawyers corporate lawyers HR
PR and More in order to make sure we
were taking all necessary Steps From The
Jump we were acutely aware of just how
contrary this was the values of the
company we've built and those of
everyone who works here
this
is something we took very seriously we
refused to sweep things under the rug
that is not who we are and it's not what
we stand for we immediately removed Ned
from work activities and engaged in HR
professional to conduct a thorough
review of the facts and we can't talk
about the details of the review but
suffice to say we found that Ned had
engaged in contact conduct Unbecoming of
our team and we knew that we could not
move forward with him so on Friday
September 16th the three of us signed
written consent of the members of second
try LLC approving the removal of Ned as
a manager and an employee we chose not
to rush into the announcement for a few
reasons namely there are real people who
have been affected and while we consider
this a company matter there's just also
a family at the center of this we also
want to remind you that the art has a
tendency to be a lot harsher towards
women than men so please we ask that you
exercise kindness things will change
here uh what we hope is that within this
there's also the opportunity for
positive growth and better videos ahead
Ah that's gonna be hard it's this whole
thing is gonna be really [ __ ] hard
and we imagine you have lots of
questions a lot more questions right now
and we're gonna have more to say in the
future uh just right now we're focused
on bringing the best content possible
between now and the end of the year and
then figuring out what the future of
this channel looks like from there
that's it for now again more to come
some things may change we're just sort
of figuring out all one day at a time
thank you for your support we appreciate
you and we look forward to introducing
you to the next era of the try guys
ahead
okay so there's the end of the video
okay so what are your thoughts I have no
thoughts I made a minute to think about
it what are my thoughts just go ahead
the reason why this gets a little bit
weird is that the woman who he slept
with a young Asian lady who's 24 I
believe
was I believe engaged to somebody else
who worked at the company
he unfollowed her on Instagram which is
how Reddit was like yo why would he even
follow his girl and the Asian girl in
the photo kind of looks like bang yo yo
listen first off the internet undefeated
the detectives they were trying to keep
this Hush Hush the detective said uh
open the door [ __ ] Tom and pay for your
taxes the IRS okay that's the thing you
can't you can't just okay you watch a
video I don't have all the Intel and
then you ask me what the [ __ ] going on I
mean wait wait wait wait wait wait
that's just gossip that's not gossip
that's messy as [ __ ] yeah no no no no
it's not just the juice wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute this
explains to me that reaction because I
didn't get it like it was okay it's just
an employee
I felt like this was a lot of PR and a
lot of things I was involved into this
now I get it the whole thing what it
really comes down to he's a married man
yes who's featured his wife and his
brand yes I love my wife guy yes and he
cheat on her with an employee yes yes
that's the real meat of the whole thing
the whole company looks messy from that
so yeah
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife my wife
my wife my wife my wife my wife I'm
married to my wife my wife my wife
to sound like professor's name so we did
a compilation real fast yeah yeah
that person's pity so
who posted a picture of herself with a
whole bag of oranges her ass hanging out
the fishnets
yes she lost her brand deal afterwards
for those photos and we said yeah this
was happening if a company doesn't want
to and if your brand is I love my wife
and you cheating on your wife with the
young employee at work sorry you gotta
go
sorry you gotta go that's your whole
brand that's your whole brand that's
your brand
you gotta go if you're if your brand is
protecting kids and you diddling kids
you gotta go I mean you gotta go period
if you're dealing kids but you get what
I'm trying to you got an extra girl
right brand or no brand yeah yeah yeah
maybe that's not the best I went but you
get what I'm trying to say that was a
[ __ ] yeah I mean like here's the thing
here's the thing oh here's a better
example we need a better example
if
Leonardo DiCaprio cheats on his wife
well she turned 25. it's what she
deserves
if 26 The Rock cheats on his wife it has
a different implication
you get what I'm trying to say yeah but
he's not gonna go that's not a good
example what you mean it's not going to
go nowhere it's not a brand he doesn't
work for his brand is not going to fire
him he's the CEO of his brand it's not
okay but it takes a hit there's huge
ramifications for what he's doing
because of how he portrays himself to
the public you understand what I'm
trying to say right so he might not hurt
himself but in terms of the family
friendly stuff there's plenty of movie
companies who won't work with them as a
result of that right because of how he's
portrayed himself to the public people
get affected differently uh based off of
what brand image they have and the
actions they engage in that's why
Leonardo DiCaprio contribute his wife
every day of the week nobody cares about
it nobody cares nobody you know what I'm
trying to say it's part of his brand so
we gotta go that's why it was such a big
deal when when Kevin Hart did it because
he put it in his brand yes and he shows
it and so I see what you're saying right
look I get that when stuff like this
happens there's going to be speculation
and gossip and we ask that you respect
the privacy of the family members and
employees who may be caught up in this I
understand what the Asian guy on the
left whistling where he's like you know
this is a private matter if you guys can
please don't speculate this and that the
problem is and this is where a lot of
like content creators lose me when they
talk about parasocial relationships it's
like people didn't invade your privacy
you brought them into your home you
introduce them to your kids you're
exposed to this you're a wife you've
made a bunch of stories you made them
part of content you made fans sound like
a big family that's some [ __ ] pop off
you're like well actually we want y'all
to back off no no no you've made them
emotionally invest in every time one
season two we're on season two episode
four of your whole of your whole life so
yeah when you you lose me content
creators who do this whole like
parasocial relationship no no it's not a
parasocial relationship you're the one
telling your audience you love them I
don't say that to my audience I don't
call my audience my family I appreciate
y'all watching we not homies we're not
friends right and I thank you guys
because most y'all when you see me in
person you're very respectful I love
that thank you shout out to you thank
you all right
but when I see these kind of situations
and they're asking for distance you
don't have the right to because you yeah
you already included them you open the
door you showed everything you show
where you live how you're inside of your
of your houseworks and stuff like that
you introduce your kids you yo there's
some people there's some people
I consider acquaintances they never met
my family like yeah I mean before you
meet my family before we meet people
around Nobby I think you don't put
people I'll take it a step further they
didn't they didn't just introduce their
family and their whatever they made it
right yeah they monetized it meaning
they made money for profit they took
these people's money or the advertising
does and they brought them profited for
me and then they want to be like take a
step back what you talking about no you
can't do that you open the door I can
understand for the people involved you
want it because now it's such a public
thing it's embarrassing you want to
protect them it's understandable
absolutely but these are the
consequences of the choices you've made
up until now that's why folks get online
and want to share everything because
everything can make money absolutely
people ask me why don't you capitalize
on this why don't you share this because
of this that's not of your business
because of this
on these certain aspects of my life to
stay privately so I should pop up y'all
have
y'all and I can demand that and I have
the right to because I never introduce
you to that that is my boundary you know
what it's just not how it works whenever
we jump on lives I'm sorry [ __ ]
oh show us the pictures of your wife and
stuff like that they've been doing that
no none of your business none your
business and then on top of the
why okay this is why people mention the
whole sex sort of thing I pretty much
guarantee you guys this that he would
not be in trouble right now this is not
a good or a bad thing I'm not telling
you what tomorrow you're at I'm just
telling you business wise he would still
be a try guy if he just hired somebody
and had some discretion Instead This
dumbass okay goes to a public event
takes one of his co-workers he's a
publicly recognizable person part of a
YouTube channel with seven million
followers okay and he's making out with
her in public
you're an idiot you got to be one of the
dumbest people I know
and the reason why I bring this up is
you can feel how you want about cheating
and listen let them hold this out he's
gonna hold it every single day of the
week now it's even worse because you've
involved employees which now legal
litigation now it's a public Affair so
now your wife is embarrassed her family
knows because here's let me tell you
something
if you're dating somebody and something
happens okay let's say she flirts with
someone or whatever it's one thing if
it's between you the person she flavored
with and that it's another thing if the
whole Community your whole job all the
friends and family know because now you
got a million different voices chiming
in you can maybe work through that
between the two of you right there's a
lot of record you know reconciliation
that can happen when you've got the
whole world involved
that adds an extra layer you got to hold
the L on so many different fronts one
for cheating two for doing it stupidly
he fumbled it back three for doing it
with an employee he fumbled a bag and
this is why people pay for sex work
y'all seen it right now they pay for the
discretion
because let me tell you that if he was
stupid and Brazen enough to do that in
public trust he's been doing this for a
long time trustee's been doing that for
a long time you don't just graduate from
Fidelity to hey
let's make up yeah no no no
no no no especially not what she dating
somebody else too that means it's been
going on for a minute oh that's
excellent
to me watching this whole situation
unfold it's like if somebody's just
[ __ ] around and they cheating on
their wife like it's not my business no
now it gets a little bit weird when it's
your brain sure now he gets extra reader
when it's your employee absolutely
absolutely
doesn't make a criminal or something but
I can understand but when I'm hearing
them do all this apologizing and stuff
like that it tells me there's got to be
more stuff in this that makes it extra
weird
that hence the reason why they were so
important yeah there has to be I imagine
but yeah Hey listen guys guys if you
start making money you're no longer a
regular person who dates regularly also
uh that's just over if you go out here
and you're gonna do some some some even
if you want to flirt with a girl and you
are and you do
that's just different now
I'm not saying it's right I'm not saying
it's fair but it is what it is and you
got a business okay so this is important
some details from the last video okay
December 2021
Alex's fiance which is the Asian girl
her fiance will went through her phone
being a Snoopy [ __ ]
and saw her Ned had hooked up while on
some work trip oh
December 2021
this is a full ass almost year ago it
was a year ago about a year ago they
ended up staying together but will
reached out to Ned the guy who cheated
on his wife
warning him to back off beginning of
this month I want to say September 1st
or 2nd will who's the guy who got
cheated on and Ned's wife
who the wife who got cheated on what
wait the two people who got cheated on
yeah okay
received videos and pictures from a few
people showing Ned and Alex the two
people who cheated back again making out
at a club as well as holding hands
during the day at a marketing NYC
Ariel who's the wife who got cheated on
had just landed in New York City to meet
up with the try guys and their
um significant others because they're
all married or whatever but got the news
at that time about the pictures she
confronted Ned and when he confirmed
it Alex had been in a relationship that
when he confirmed that him and Alex
basically saying like him you know we
were she kind of been in a relationship
for almost a year she got back on the
plane and came back to L.A immediately
when the try guys had toxic employees
many said they noticed Florida and knew
they had lunch hookups and stayed at
each other's places occasionally I'm
gonna show up to events together
and I had big feels something was up so
they've known for this for a hot minute
yeah
so what we said earlier about the hack
that this is going on for a long time
you don't just graduate today yeah
absolutely and and also when I'm saying
that it's just blood of proportion and
now other people knew it's where the fan
knew that they started to be like okay
now we need to do a thing and it isn't
and then you know
it's when the public you understand and
that's what I said and that's why and it
goes with what I was saying before when
I said okay that's why they're making a
big deal out of it because not a public
see how messy it is yeah that's what I
meant with that is that there was there
was something really
uh people sending pictures of this and
that the Public's knowing now your whole
brand looks bad it looks rotten from
inside right oh yeah yeah so so so so
now your whole brand
your whole brand looks like an enabler
from that thing to happen because they
know that it's been going on for a long
time people know that [ __ ] the people
are involved lawyers stuff and that and
that's what I'm saying oh okay I
understand why they're making a big deal
out of it because now it looks bad
I mean maybe or maybe it's because once
they found out they started to go
through the process in private and it
just so happened to go public
Maybe fair but I but I still and I mean
we noticed this if you guys all know
each other and you guys all know each
other's wives and you guys are all
spending time together and you find out
homies cheating on his wife with one of
your employees you probably go through
the process and get fired him too yeah
but just even with the flirting and he
like you don't talk to him you're like
yo
the [ __ ] is going on the [ __ ] is this
time you pick up [ __ ] on some of the
people you work with you pick up Vibes
you know what I think about you know
what I asked though is this just
confirmation bias
what do you mean meaning like
sometimes you expect to have them but
you're not really sure so you let it go
you know what I'm saying then it happens
you're like [ __ ] I knew the whole time
yeah I know I know I know which is I
understand what you're saying
you know the way that these guys came up
that this is probably a big deal for all
them so you know I'm trying to I'm
trying to be charitable trying to be
terrible you know
seems like when they found out a month
ago they started going through the
process because they were editing them
out of every video they were pretty much
scrubbing them clean and that's not a
short process he stopped working with
them once they found out according to
this timeline so you know got to give
them some new difference there but
anyway sure all this to say
I'm not all cheating is created equal
and uh my friend
this is the way you did it it's got to
be the dumbest way and the worst way you
didn't just cheat [ __ ] you had a
full-on affair
there's a difference
there's a difference there is ask most
wives they'll tell you if he [ __ ] a
prostitute that's one thing if you just
if you're out here kissing and holding
hands they're trying to get a [ __ ]
pregnant that's the that's the first
thing they're gonna ask that's
everything is your lover that's the
first thing a lot of them will say that
first thing there's people who say no
cheating whatsoever and there's people
but even even if there's the no cheating
whatsoever like there's no cheating
whatsoever yeah but once a [ __ ]
finds out yeah like after all the raw
raw [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] gonna be like
okay but tell me one thing yeah they're
gonna ask you so but but what's their
feelings yeah people are going to want
to know if there's feelings what does
this mean to you yeah well this is the
thing of opportunity when was it ego
what was it oh there was actually Felix
and I feel I feel like feelings hurt
more sure like if there was like if you
if you if you if you okay y'all build
this whole [ __ ] if it's just a it hurts
it already hurts
it hurts
but the fact that you had you built a
whole other [ __ ] that hurts more I think
so this I'll confirm what you just said
um on one of my Instagram stories I
asked I said ladies what would you
prefer
your significant other cheated on you or
your significant other decked you in the
face full force punch right to your jaw
possibly breaking your face what would
you prefer
no they chose violence they'd rather
they chose violence every single one of
them every almost every single one of
them said I'd rather get punched at full
force by my
then himchi
now my Jew
um
maybe they just don't know what it's
like to get punched
with their frame and their husband maybe
they don't know
because let me tell you you let a man
wind up he could kill your ass
you know what I'm saying some of you
tiny ass ladies I had women who were
five foot Hobbits bro nah Lord of the
Rings the Fellowship Hey listen they're
taking the Hobbits to eyes and God you
get me y'all riding trees and [ __ ]
got a little furry feet I just thought
of something and you getting punched
before you probably go die and then like
give it to me
it's different don't it imagine
oh my God I can't believe you oh [ __ ]
it's not that bad God damn whoa do it
again [ __ ]